[موسيقى]
وام العريس فرحانه
قوي وان شاء الله ربي يهنيها
[موسيقى]
الفستان بالنسبه لي
الملكه اكيد لما لبسته اعطته هيدا الطابع
اللي
بفوق اي شيء ممكن واحد يكون تعب واشتغل
عليه وحلم فيه انه يطلع بعيد بالشكل
[موسيقى]
سوق تم اختيار الفستان من مجموعه ربيع سيف
من اول ما كنت عم بشتغل على هيدا كان كتير
طول الوقت عم تفكر انه ما بيليق الا بحدا
مثل
[موسيقى]
وبيقولوا لي انه اختارت هيدا القفطان
لتلبسوا للحنه
من ابرز التفاصيل الموجوده بالكفطان هو
طريقه شغله بالتطريز في كثير تفاصيل من
خيط الحرير لخيط القصب المستعملين وشي شي
مجموج بين شيط وراس وبنفس الوقت شي
ناعم وراقي
الاختيار كان اخذ معنا
بكتير تفاصيل
وطبعا يعني شي بده يضيق كمان بحضرتها
الى ان وصلنا
لهالاندماج بالالوان وبالماتي اللي هي
بتعطي هيدا اللوك الراقي نفس الوقت في
فخامه
القفطان بتاخذ تقريبا ثلاثه اشهر لاربعه
اشهر
نحن كان وقتنا شوي ضيق ولكن
كنا عم ننجز كل مرحله بمرحلتها بعنايه
شديده
كنا عم نلحق كل التفاصيل مد قماش من
النوعيه من طريقه القصه كمان لو وصلنا
لوقت اخر فتره لاخر اسبوعين كنا الكل مش
عم يناموا لحتى حققنا هذا الانجاز
ما في شك انه كل شي طلبته الملكه
بتعديل الفستان من الكولكشن لائق ودقيق
لشيء هي بتحبوه
انا برايي كان كل شي بمحله ميه بالميه كان
كثير هالتفاصيل
كمان عنيف لانه هي عم تلبس شيء مميز غير
الكولكشن حتى اللون الازرق كان نقطه مهمه
كتير
اللي هي انه طبعا
العروس الوحيده اللي بتحب تلبس او الابيض
لتتميز بهيك مناسبه
والملكه كان لون تحديدا يعني عطاه عطاه
طابع حلو للكف من ناحيه المناسبه كحلنا من
ناحيه كالون هي كمان بتحبه كتير
وحتى التفاصيل الموجوده بالقفطان كمان
اعطت زياده شمال لانه لونه ازرق
الملكه رانيا
علقت كم تعليق كتير كانوا
بسيطين وحلوين انه من اجمل الفساتين اللي
شافتهم
من اجمل الالوان اللي بست عليها كمان يعني
هيدا النهار 23/5 بعتبروا كثير كثير حلو
كان يعني كان اول صوره بتوصلني كيف انلبس
يعني عن جد هيك وجد خمس دقايق بس عم
بستمتع قد ايه حلو هذا الشعور انه فعلا
شفت فستاني لبستوا الملكه رانيا
[موسيقى]